I'm going to walk you through
my thought process on how I
built this responsive
weather forecast page.
Typically, when I'm trying to pick
my breakpoints, I'll start in
my desktop browser with my viewport
set as small as I can get it.
I also like to have the Chrome DevTools
open because it shows me
the screen width in the upper right-hand
corner as I resize the window.
Next, I'll slowly start
resizing the window,
looking to see when the content
tells me that it wants a breakpoint.
And probably somewhere here,
at about the 550 pixel mark,
looks like a good place.
Anything wider and
the spaces between these columns
are going to become too big.
In my code,
I've already got my viewport set and
a default set of styles that
are applied for any viewport width.
I'll add weather-medium.css to the head
with a media query that checks for
a screen and if the viewport
width is greater than 550 pixels.
Great.
I'll switch back to the browser,
hit Refresh, and start to resize.
Perfect.
At 550 pixels,
things look exactly like I expect.
Because that breakpoint
was only at 550 pixels,
I think I probably
want to add another one.
Otherwise, we'll run into
the same problem with too much
space between columns.
I easily have a room for
another one since most desktops and
laptops are significantly
wider than 550 pixels.
I'll go through the same process, and
I'll continue to expand the viewport
until it looks like I
need another breakpoint.
Again, I'm looking for
a place where the content tells
me that it wants a breakpoint.
700 pixels looks to be right
about the right place.
So, I'm going to go ahead and
add one here.
Again, I'll add a new style sheet,
but this time,
point it at weather-large.css.
It'll check for screen and
check to see if the viewport
width is at least 700 pixels.
A quick refresh in the browser and
resize.
And we've got it.
Things are looking good.
I could keep adding breakpoints, but
in this case, I think having two
breakpoints is enough, essentially one
at a small viewport, one at a medium
viewport, and one at a large viewport.
Okay, that's enough of me talking.
Now it's your turn to give it a try.